j'suis là attention les chroniqueurs et
chez vous essayez de deviner qui a le
bon ticket à l'hôte est dégueulasse et
attention c'est pas qu'elle regagne un
truc vas-y tu ahmed ahmed quelques trucs
dégueulasses moi les gars c'est moi qui
ai truc dégueulasse il aurait cessé la
commedia dell'arte ça c'est le ici si je
t'assure ahmed serri l'huile de foie de
morue dénonce robert jobin et mobiles de
sardines 3e 3e à la barre à l'état ahmed
j'ai compris c'est la théorie du tabasco
donc derniers mois je sais pas lequel
est bon le calibre des rides sert il
c'est moi au lieu qu'ils ont misé
commence doucement tu vois ça on a tous
reconnu c'est qu'on ne sait plus trop
qui je fais des retournés de tête et
tout à huawei fait des retournés de tête
mais avec les perruques ou sur les
perruques à avec un mec a fait comme
c'est facile avec les plus grands manon
même avec les paires utilisons à peu
près trois femmes au niveau
scemama me sens bien
[Applaudissements]
dans les détails
ça suffit à ceux qui sont bons la cgil
ou celle qui avait racheté le temps plus
difficiles cela arrive à cela il est
subtile ok nathan faut que je m'assieds
suis là si géraldine géraldine ces
vilains oui je vous ai offert un livre
ni le prendre voilà c'est celui ci
ouvrait à la fuite et oui vous avez bien
vous lisez des trucs non je n'ai pas lu
n'a rien dedans n'y a rien c'est une
autobiographie de la carrière de leurs
maux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]